now we have that with the women one
uh are women exactly the same as men or
better now we have we're running several
programs at once in our society women
are absolutely the same and a bit better
how
not small sources christine lagarde head
of the imf
repeatedly said in the decades since the
crash that if lehman brothers had been
layman's sisters it might not have
happened why
why either women are have equal
competence to men in the financial
system
or they're different
or they're different and better
so which is it christine lagarde the
head of the imf keeps on pumping out
this idea they're better we wouldn't
have financial crashes if we had women
uh more prominent in finance
it's very hard to sustain all of these
ideas in your head at the same time and
not go a bit bad well that's the point
isn't it because that that her argument
is actually one that i personally agree
with which is i think if we had more
women in those industries in the top
positions right because women are less
they're more risk averse
right on average right and there are
other differences between men and women
on average you may well end up with with
a company behavior that is different if
you have more women in those positions
but what that requires you to accept of
course is that men and women are
different are different
virtues signaling no constantine i'm not
sure that's what you're saying i'm gonna
get in trouble just for saying it no but
but but also i mean
again if we got to that stage you then
have to work out do we want
less risk in the banking sector and if
so is it the case that we need to pump
women in in order to do that more
um what are the sectors where we need
the power i mean this isn't a new motif
the idea of the pacifying female force
to stop them rampaging mail
but where are for instance the occasions
when we might need the rampaging mail
you know
there must be times or loads
firefighters you know police officers
right and we have all these endless
painful dementing campaigns to get more
women in the fire service and
you know uh uh persuade them that this
is this is the career for them and then
we're just horrified at the fact that
the stats don't seem to be going up in
enough order and
and um
i just think it's it's it again it's
it's it's a it's it's something we know
it's something we can't talk about and
so we've decided to lie about
but but one of the interesting i'm going
to get on the cuttlefish if it kills me
[Laughter]
douglas has been trying for 35 minutes
to get to the country but it's a great
example
because
because i think is
clever the clever people
um the socially advantaged people as
well you might say
work out how to get through dementing
eras a bit faster
and can do so and then lambast the
people who didn't make it you know
didn't catch up in time didn't alter
their behavior and their language fast
enough
and
uh
the most the clearest example of this i
would say is in the behavior of males
towards women in the sort of
post me to era
and uh
i when i was researching the madness of
crowds i had the great pleasure of
speaking through some of the themes of
it with a bewildering array of friends
in a bewildering array of different
disciplines one of my favorite
conversations was with a friend of the
biologist who
just one day was describing to me the
behavior of the cuttlefish there's a
forest which is the mimic octopus as
well but the
the cuttlefish um
have an extraordinary um
interesting thing about them which is
that there's a type of cuttlefish where
because the male to female ratios is bad
it advantages the females against the
males
and because the females tend to go
around with their male cuttlefish
it's hard for the male cuttlefish who
are single bachelor cuttlefish you might
say
to uh in cell i think it is special no
no no no no neither so these are not
these are not yet in the cell
they could become
fish but they have a strategy and their
strategy is
that because the female cuttlefish is
smaller than the male cuttlefish uh the
male cuttlefish in search of a bit of
action
can pretend to be to assume the the form
of a female
and they they become smaller
and because the woman is going around
with her consort male cuttlefish and the
male cuttlefish is alert for other
cuttlefish competition
they pretend to be smaller they go
around the female the male thinks that
they're not a threat and by being small
and diminutive they get through and then
they have their wicked way
now
the
the
the moment this friend said this to me i
just said oh my god it's
i know so many men doing that
i know so many men it's a creepy male
feminist yeah it is that's what it is
this absolutely is a creepy male
feminist and by the way i had a very
specific example of a colleague of mine
the spectator freddie gray uh had
covered the um
uh [ __ ] hat protests the anti-trump uh
protests the women's march just
immediately after the inauguration in
2017. and he had told me uh uh uh that
among very interesting things that
happened that day
and again none of this is to say you
know what people complain about donald
trump wasn't you know didn't have any
legitimacy you know uh uh or that he'd
behaved like a perfect gentleman you
know i think we could probably all agree
that wasn't the case
but uh
what was interesting to me was what this
colleague told me about something that
happened at the end of the day because
all these young men uh from the sort of
you know
ivy league young men among others who
are on the on the women's march
and there's a party afterwards uh that
this uh colleague friend turns up at and
uh uh all these men are saying around i
can't do the american accent but i can
do the british equivalent which is like
yeah yeah so totally like on board with
this like yeah [ __ ] trump uh and they're
all doing this and like yeah i totally
totally support like
and
that's when the women are around
and when the last woman
leaves this particular group to go off
and get some beer
one of the other guys
goes to the other oh my god dude i can't
believe how much [ __ ] there is in this
room
[Laughter]
but it's funny isn't it like we have an
example of a right now uh we're
recording this uh in the moment of
justin trudeau being uh being chased and
harassed and whatever for i mean how
much did he black up yeah
i mean it's almost a fetish we've got
three on video already but presumably
there were just evenings he just sat at
home you know not on video just enjoying
a bit of blacking up i mean
well he actually said he doesn't know
how many times he's done it yeah well
you know
i've been browning up all my life so
yeah everyone's got to have a hobby
haven't they but but the thing with that
is that i put you know dressing up as a
light into me i don't see what's racist
about that i don't know i don't think i
think i don't think we need to actually
destroy justin trudeau for that reason
but the hypocrisy of it this woke
chieftain of of the universe being the
guy who's been doing the blackface yes
to me is an inevitable reality don't you
find it might be evidence of the
existence of god
i don't think it's all been said
we've all been certainly reading it
comes in the form of justin trudeau
blackface
justice and karma i love it but actually
none of the three of us are believers of
course but perhaps we'll be converted by
this very incident
maybe the iconography would be really
confusing in future generations well he
does work in mysterious ways
[Music]
you